Some knitters will choose to use a heavier-
than-recommended yarn on their
standard gauge machine.
Remember, the criteria for the correct
yarn to use on your machine has to do
with the yarn being able to fit
in the hooks of the needles.
And there has to be enough
room between the needles.
So the stitches form properly.
And often-used trick is to knit with every
other needle. You still have to swatch,
but your swatch may not be knit  according
to the rules for a standard gauge machine.
Normally, we would measure 40 stitches
and 60 rows with a green ruler.
For this example, we're going to measure
over our choice of stitches and rows and use
a regular ruler to calculate our gauge.
Take a look at my swatch.
I've marked and measured over 20 stitches.
I've knit 60 rows between the row markers.
Just looking at the swatch,
you don't know what machine I used and you
certainly can't tell that I knit
this swatch over every other needle.
The point is, no matter what your needle
arrangement, we are counting
stitches, not needles.
Take a look at the same
swatch on the machine,
I pulled 73 needles
and then I put 38 needles into work
and put every other needle
into out of work position.
I did an e-wrap Cast-on and started
knitting.
And as I knit, I was forming 38 total
stitches and marked 20 to use
for my swatch measurement.
When I took the knitting off the machine,
it didn't look like much.
You can see the channels between
the stitches and the stitches
look really tiny.
I grabbed a swatch by the Cast-on
and Bindoff edges and gave it a tug.
This reformed the stitches
and they look great.
Don't be afraid of stretching too much.
But with all that tugging and stretching,
you must let that poor swatch rest.
At least overnight, before
you block it and measure it.
To really get a feel for the importance
of letting a swatch rest.
Please work this exercise.
Knit a swatch and measure
it right off the machine.
Stretch the knitting lengthwise to pop
and reform those stitches and measure it
again. You're going
to see a huge difference.
Let the swatch rest for a few
hours and measure again.
Let it rest overnight at least,
and measure it again, writing
down the measurements each time.
Then block your swatch treat it as you're
going to treat your final
garment and measure.
You're going to see a big difference
in the gauge each step of the way.
I hope you won't be tempted to start
knitting based on the gauge
of the knitting taken right off
the machine without letting it rest.
Please don't get confused when
you're knitting every other needle.
You're measuring and counting stitches,
not needles.
So keep that in mind when you're following
the knitting instructions as well.